julio aureus in the first inning this
year has an era above 10. once he gets
through that he's up
to what's he got to do to change the
tour early in audis
well his skipper and his pitching coach
wanted him to be more aggressive and for
me that would be the attitude that he
brings out of the bullpen bring out
the reliever in you instead of the
starter that's trying to ease into the
outing so
we'll watch the radar gun here in the
first inning see if he's around 93 94
maybe even touch 95.
timla cash will step into the batter's
box or his is ready to go
it's a swing and a miss and starts his
night with a strikeout
aureus is off to the good start lefty
alex young who keeps
increasing his pitch count as he
transitions for the bullpen to the
rotation over his last three starts he's
up to 90 pitches
seven appearances out of the bullpen for
the diamondbacks before going back
into the rotation one started against
the padres one against the a's one
against the rockies last time out five
innings five hits three runs
now he gets to pay spooky bets to lead
things up good pitch right there that
curveball down from alex young and he
strikes out mookie betts
dodgers now have the bases loaded and
one out with chris taylor coming up
four pitch walk to taylor to give the
dodgers the game's first run
faces loaded walk chris taylor and it's
one nothing here in the first
back to the top and bets sharply but at
the short stop on that
low throw walker couldn't hang on and
that's the board to keep the second
inning going
that'll be an error on the throw i'm
sure you'll see that from nick
ahmed very often keeps us in and alive
for seeger
seeger pops it up into center varsity is
there under it
and dalton makes a catch and that'll end
the ending no runs an air
and a man left on base one pitch one out
there's carson kelly
kelly hits one deep to left field [ __ ]
hernandez on the track it's drifting to
the wall and carson kelly
takes it out of here we are tied at one
that ball just kept going back
i was watching hernandez he was drifting
to his left
and then all of a sudden started to back
pedal run out of room as he
got to the warning track and that ball
sailed into the bleachers
pollux at second base taylor walked with
the bases loaded in his first hat back
punches it down the line barrels are
overrated but rbi's aren't
and to the corner pollock into score
taylor to second two on dodgers
second rbi of the night and the dodgers
now lead the diamond backs two to one
now he can play all over the lot
he can hit it all over the line jam [ __ ]
hernandez with the bases loaded and
nobody out there's a fly ball to center
hit it pretty well marshall goes back at
the wall out there and he leaps
caught the ball and everybody tags and
advances
a sacrifice fly but a nice play out
there by marshall
who took an extra base hit away from
mccreek hernandez to make the
first out of the inning the dodgers lead
three to one and here is rio
fly ball center field easy play for far
show he's there
tagging and scoring is taylor
that makes it four to one so brios gets
the job done
knocking him his seventh run of the year
aj pollock
two for three a single a double and a
strikeout today and they drive into left
trouble and le castro makes a nice
sliding catch
gets the ball back in the runners have
to return boy timla castro used every
bit of that speed he's got
to take a hit away and probably a run
maybe more
from the dodgers with that sliding catch
on the warning dragon left
pets to third and seeger to second now
taylor
stroke to right on a line calhoun
misjudged it and it's over his head to
bring home
two taylor stops at second
and the dodgers lead at 6-1 i mean it
was a line drive right
right at him whatever it did it ended up
over his head and
boy is he embarrassed about it so he's
going to be out of the bullpen alana
told us during the pregame show that
he was uh very agreeable to the decision
said
whatever i got to do to be a part of
this realize that probably not a spot in
the rotation form at this point
happy to come in on whatever role he can
serve and it will be in relief
strike three called way for him to start
his time back healthy
one out and carson kelly coming up kelly
who swings and misses and he's down on
strikes
6-1 lead on arizona with two out in the
top half of the eighth inning
martay with a fly ball to fairly deep
right center field racing over chris
taylor to make the catch
and that's gonna do it in the eighth see
the numbers for alexander not a big time
strikeout pitcher but he will put the
ball
on the ground only zach britton has
induced a higher ground ball percentage
since
2015 than scott alexander the dodgers
one out away from their 27th win
and nick's swings down the left field
line that ball is going to go
nick cometh into the dodger bullpen and
that cuts the lead in half to six to
three well a walk kept it going
and ahmed hits his fourth of the year he
likes hitting the dodgers
he likes hitting in dodgers stadium he
struck him out and that will do it
we'll take a little more work in this
ninth inning than they would have liked
but ultimately it's a 6-3 win